هذا واحد من المباني التي انهارت عند
الزلزال الاول في اللحظات الاولى كان
المبنى مؤلفا من اربع طبقات فرق الانقاذ
كما ترون لا تزال تعمل في الموقع حتى الان
هناك اكثر من 30 شخصا عالقين تحت الانقاض
فرق الانقاذ تحاول بين الحين والاخر
استخدام معدات قد تدل على وجود مؤشرات
حياه داخل الركام لكن ما يصعب العمل هو
كثافه الثلوج المتراكمه التي تتحول الى
كتل جليديه مع الهواء البارد هناك تواجد
لعناصر من الجيش التركي ايضا لاعانه فرق
الانقاذ المدنيه المنظر هنا
صعب للغايه هؤلاء الذين ترونهم الان هم
عائلات الضحايا الذين لا يزالون تحت
الانقاض يجلسون امام المبنى ولكن يجلسون
بصمت بحزن
وبثقل ما ما جرى لهم عائلاتهم يجلسون بصمت
ينتظرون اي خبر
من فرق الالقاد سنحاول التحدث الى
سيده
اذا السيده
تقول انها هنا تنتظر اي خبر عن ابنها وعن
عائله ابنها هو مع زوجته وطفليه لا يزالان
عالقان تحت انقاذ هذا المبنى السيدات
وايضا الرجال هنا
جميعهم لديهم عائلات
ينتظرون اي خبر من فرق الانقاذ فرق
الانقاذ لا تزال تعمل
بمعدات بدائيه يدويه انا مررت منذ يوم امس
والفريق برفقتي ليلى على اربعه من المدن
العشره الاكثر تضررا
بدانا في اضنه في عثمانيه وصلنا الى
كهرمان مارش الدمار كبير جدا وثم اتينا
الى هنا غازي عنتاب ايضا كلس وثم اتينا
صباح هذا اليوم توكلنا من الوصول الى
ملاطيا من حسب ما شاهدت من المدن التي
مررنا فيها بعد كهرمان مراش قد تكون
ملاطيا ثاني اكثر مدينه متضرره من المدن
العشر الاساسيه التي تضررت في الزلزال
الدمار في احياء المدينه بشكل كبير ليلى
هناك اسواق بالكامل انهارات تقدر فرق
الانقاذ عدد المباني التي انهارت في
مالاتيا ب 300 مبنى حتى الان تم انتشار
اكثر من
شخصا من تحت الانقاذ ولكنهم كانوا قد
فرقوا الحياه
[موسيقى]